let's make some money
battlecry is the model for this crew
sure but also for this rebooted movie
franchise I know we be robbing banks by
now that's some gas truck in the middle
nowhere isn't this something you say
before you go to rob the gas truck in
the middle of nowhere movie expects me
to believe this go into reverse via you
brake turn maneuver is possible at 60
miles an hour his pickup truck can
travel in Reverse at the same speed as a
semi truck on the highway because well
this is only the beginning of this crap
and you know it well that's some
bullshit why doesn't everyone have the
same hands-free headset that Letty does
it's really strange to me that during
these heists absolutely no one else
drives on these roads the one thing they
never counted on was the truck driver
seeing something on in his mirrors this
bullet hits exactly in the spot where
Corrado's torso is and only has to worry
about his shattered glass oh no
something this guy pumps the brakes once
then bails at a lot of miles per hour
and lives how has this gas tank on fire
not exploded yet sometimes an exciting
scene is so much bullshit the danger is
it real anymore after this there's no
reason to feel any tension spectacular
explosion just for the hell of it all
the excitement of the first movie
without the those movie is a dick to
epileptics but is kind of a good friend
to my boner
so I'm conflicted none of the girls in
any of these shots is my girlfriend so
they stole a gas truck to use for
illegal street races is gas that hard to
come by don't you bet pink slips and how
is a $40 Philip that big a deal time for
you to go do her dare done some crazy in
Tokyo like nearly drifting this
franchise into obscurity
damn how long have we been doing I have
no idea but I'm gonna get us long enough
to know better figure it out you always
do man that's touching I really hope
these criminals find a happy ending DOM
is a dick to Letty but at least he left
the cash on the nightstand like she's a
whore running Paul Walker B block how's
the movie so far gentlemen jump cut
chase scene has no intention of letting
you get your bearings randos security
guard goes out like a bitch and gives up
his gun so the scene can have added
tension jeez just call backup dude you
had no place to go they both survived
this day David Clarke amazing I can
remember that after crashing through in
car why am I even alive David Park I
could throw a fortune cookie out this
150 David parks right now that's super
racist also that's one magic fortune
cookie wait how did
get another job after absolutely thing
the police rulebook the last movie she's
murdered because you left her alone most
likely also amazing that her death means
so little of his franchise it wasn't
even shown on the screen
probably so they can bring her back
later everyone in the movie decides to
believe led he's dead without seeing a
body which is convenient beyond words
facial recognition software imagine
Toretto about 10 minutes after cross a
border thought he'd show even though I
supposedly have comp instincts there's
no reason for me to check other areas of
the cemetery where he might be watching
the funeral also how is it that you
don't have anyone watching the streets
in and around the cemetery just in case
he shows up anywhere near the area out
of 360 degrees Brian chooses to
dramatically look in the one spot where
DOM had actually been cops are staking
out this home but not the back way which
Dom so obviously used to sneak in here
they're staking the place out if they
find you well that's all I have to say
about that
anyway accounts are don't daddy wouldn't
let them junk it you mean the cops Letty
wouldn't allow law enforcement to junk
the car isn't it their property after
that Brian Dom drag race at the end of
the first movie the crash I'm going to
crack this case because in addition to
being a badass car heist guy I'm also an
honorary Scotland Yard sleuth we don't
make serious inroads into the Braga case
in the next 72 hours they're gonna shut
us down because it's been two years and
the last three agents we sent to
infiltrate his organization have come
back in body bags so basically the
government will be cool with all his
illegal activities after that because
this case is too damn hard
also you sent three other undercover
dudes before sending Brian undercover
God O'Connor the Boy Toretto's rich goes
and spotted in his own neighborhood
brings a son despite this fact will let
him drive all the way here and then
we're going to show up after Dom does a
Sherlock Holmes routine because nobody
in law enforcement is worth a shit
Vin Diesel is fast and curious oh he can
actually create memories of an accident
he knows nothing about by merely
standing on this road he is really good
at deducing he found something back
there yes memories that are not from my
own brain
burn marks on the ground the kind that
could only be caused by natural death
there's only one guy in all of itself
this is something the detectives
couldn't figure out this is fucking
police work 101 also what a bunch of
bullshit one guy one fucking guy saw
something that is this coveted in the
street-racing world one guy Sin City
stylized driving shot brought to you by
Sin City I've narrowed it down to 50 or
so David parks I want you to throw a
fortune cookie at them like that racist
agent was talking about earlier see
which one flinches that's your man don't
put your hands on me again okay say hi
to your sister for me
Jesus what world does this dude live in
Eureka brought of it the part Brian
might be one of the worst agents in
history ladies murder case didn't lead
Brian to the same information Dom just
got the only guy who sells nitromethane
in the area and the one guy who knows
what David Park and his car look like
well I did well no I lied to DOM I lied
to everybody that's why I do best that's
why the feds recruited me Brian's
amazing lying was so renowned they
recruited him for it of course how did
they know he was a liar if he was so
good at it and Brian didn't get in any
trouble for letting the girl go
yesterday by tricking the other FBI guy
in faking transfer orders 98 Saturn and
95 Sebring and 98 Nissan 240 with an
illegal mark
that's it why didn't you plug in all the
David parks with an illegal mod of the
database and narrow the search time down
Jesus do I have to do everything for you
fate and the screenwriter have conspired
to get Brian and Dom to investigate the
same guy at the same exact time I'll
just get you in the race war Riggs guy
who's spilling his guts somehow the
signs to stop so that this window
breakage can happen either that or
Toretto threw him through the window
before giving him time to answer the
question
there is no freaking way Park was able
to hold on to a curtain after being
dangled out of a window by his feet and
then drunk Connor do you know the
difference between a cop and a criminal
boy one bad judgment call whether or not
you mean to you're saying that all cops
have avoided making one bad judgment
call which is preposterous we have Intel
that Braga's number two Ramon Campos
will hold the street race in Koreatown
tomorrow night to fill a slot on his
team let me guess winner gets the slot
did you just say let me guess and then
fill in the rest of the sentence with
information the first dude already said
this double fisted montage of car work
makes me fucking angry are they gonna
mirror each other the entire film do you
want us parks guys blondie
I'm wondering how does a guy who blew
his cover in the first movie you get to
go undercover in the same street racing
world a second time with nobody noticing
it my job is to find the best drivers
period whoever wins the race gets the
info seems like a weird way to get your
trusted drivers you run one race
something that could easily ended a
fluke and that's how you pick people
revving tires satellite maps sure what a
deuce
can he even hear you with all this noise
is it possible for a car and only two
wheels to move faster than cars on four
wheels I'm sure it is but it probably
requires either sluggishness on the part
of the other drivers or those two tires
touching the ground moving at a speed
twice that of any other cars tires which
is kooky right 2009 movie makes a chia
pet reference yet will spawn at least
three more sequels because there is no
God no cops were called in the running
of this massively inconvenient Street
race by and should definitely have
killed some pools here but for the power
of screenwriting so our job and then
this car proceeds to bust through a
wooden staircase and down a hill without
stalling or busting tires at least we
know you can't beat me straight up I
didn't know there were rules true that
Dom it actually makes me wonder why you
guys didn't start racing immediately
before the countdown got to zero within
this kind of race reward cheaters stupid
guy is getting his stupid face arrested
during sexual relations cliche wherever
this is going on cops would be noticing
this is some loud invasive shit right
here this girl's ass is not my
girlfriend in this scene I mean this
girl is not my ass in the city I mean
this ass is not oh yeah Carolla tom
orders without the waitress even
acknowledging him this is absolutely
totally ok are we still going with the
idea that DOM is the only guy who
recognizes Brian this guy's face was
everywhere in that first movie also her
you just got out of County
when Brian arrested David Park the race
was the very next night so how do Brian
get that just got out of County street
cred don't undercover guys have to
actually be in jail for a while so that
it can be verified they simply go on
parks word which I cannot believe is how
this worked considering how hard Braga
is to find any one of them would die for
bitanga including you especially me even
though brian is a dumbass and doesn't
realize it Braga basically just gave
away his identity this is the guy who's
so hard to find this is the guy who's
killed three other FBI guys before he
could be identified rod is mine I'm
taking two more house staff and also
talking about it in front of a club full
of people you were just told are so
loyal to Braga they died for this room
with the boss is no longer important to
guard now that a girl with a hot ass
just walked by how does Brian know this
door isn't leading to a single dead end
room at which point he'll be caught by
the boss man for snooping answer he
thing doesn't thang like Ryan everything
about the layout of the rest of this
building cooperates with his
eavesdropping same here Don has no clue
where this elevator will take him but
whatever can we just go back to the
three girls kissing are you one of those
boys who prefers cars to women I'm one
of those boys that appreciates a fine
body regardless of the neck are we at a
James Bond film all the sudden a dirty
shot glass just what I always wanted
how in the fuck did Brian get into the
office where Braga was drinking without
being seen so that means I have to
contact individual agencies and that
could take weeks fingerprints somehow
take weeks of verification but hey
that's convenient for the plot so that's
something we have going for us
yep that's your third traffic violation
in less than three blocks is this guy
serious doesn't you know what Braga
expects from his drivers he's stopped
thanks movie narrator bad guy gives
potential undercover agents plenty of
time to destroy any bugs they might have
in their cars by making it way too
obvious and not inspecting all the cars
at the exact same time also it makes you
wonder how dumb the other FBI guys were
to get killed by this guy also luckily
brian has an unfinished can of nos in
which he can throw this bug that's some
seriously convenient product placement
right there I don't have entirely on the
target repeat I don't have a tally on
the target so the FBI knows that Brian
went into this one place but when a huge
truck comes driving out of it they don't
follow it for any reason how do you
build a tunnel like this on the Mexico
border without anyone ever noticing get
ready guys through the drivers who are
driving as fast as they can need anyone
telling them to get out as fast as they
can
seven two plumber her name was Letty DOM
spills all his cards during Mexican
desert standoff with bad guys that have
guns somebody worked the car I wrecked a
car so you can tell this is guy bent on
revenge why don't you just go ahead and
kill him right now last time I saw it it
was burning the Dom you have presented
in these movies would crush the
speaker's neck right here and now even
if he has some nice cigarette lighter
bomb ready to explode soon come on you
know I get caught somehow I'll be able
to guide us back over the Mexican border
without my FBI but he's tracking us not
to mention Border Patrol
wait Donna's getting in the Humvee with
Brian and leaving without killing the
guy that killed Letty what was all that
about that there's seriously no cameras
on an impound lot and what happens when
they drive out of here in a completely
different car and there's a smash window
on the driver's side does the card say
okay you move along
not in there do you have x-ray vision or
something Korona continues their assault
on your good taste with second egregious
product placement I have no idea where
they are now and the sister had to drive
to get to this oil field trailer but
somehow there is a box full of Letty
memories for Dawn to sift through magic
I wonder how much of a discount does
Campbell's Soup get for product
placement that is blurry as hell but
still obvious Don knows who killed Letty
but he's unnecessarily curious about who
she was talking to before she died so
that he and Bryan can fight there for
you Tom good for you Bryan weights a
stupid amount of time in this fight to
share the fight stopping information
with a single this brush Brian removes
all the blood caused by ten punches to
the face dawn through a second ago let's
use the shipment to lure Braga lop the
head off a multi-billion dollar cartel
and how do you suggest we do that a
hand-to-hand exchange with Braga
he'll know sure you can't afford not to
you just said this was a
multibillion-dollar cartel the shipment
you're talking about is 60 million sorry
to say Braga isn't gonna stick his head
out for that but for the movie he will
what do you want delivered by Braga
himself well that's not a suspicious way
of trying to get Braga at the meeting
nope not at all
O'Conner hasn't given us a signal yet
Porter that didn't you understand we
just got confirmation do it cuz that's
how if bi operations are done you go
against the plan midstream because you
got a suppose at fingerprint match in an
extremely fluid situation this isn't
much of a surprise so I guess we'll soon
dramatic irony here machine guns go off
in every possible direction and somehow
everyone doesn't die this henchgirl for
some reason runs out and stops in front
of her bosses speeding car
I guess so Don could save her and she
could be in future sequels wait are you
telling me that absolutely no FBI guys
are around to stop this car just in case
this exact thing happens is under your
nose the whole time you know he's right
he should have known but even with
intuition he had to verify fingerprints
which somehow take weeks to verify even
if you're in the FBI tread is hitting
south while all across the border by now
despite the fact that we have facial
recognition software that verifies this
type issue and should know he hasn't
crossed the border yet the first bad guy
you helped escape the laws grasp
actually he is he's just done it twice
for the same person now of course none
of the angry at Brian FBI agents are
sticking out to read hos house because
that would make too much sense
everyone's looking for you but not here
for some reason
hey you're crying I've got just the
thing for that so let's right here in
the kitchen because God knows there's no
way your brother Dom will stumble upon
such a horrific sight if it's so easy to
cross the Mexican border while
drama going through the Batman tunnels
and to get a shipment just admit to me
you created that scene through the
tunnels so you can have a cool car scene
I'm a big boy
you can tell me something about this no
passing scene is keeping me from paying
attention to the note passing I can't
quite put my finger on it this is where
my jurisdiction being that I'm not an
FBI agent anymore I don't really have
jurisdiction anywhere I don't even know
why I said that now they aren't all
black but these are definitely
tailgating SUVs two of the three
telltale signs of levo convoy hey
remember what hot chick I'll never bang
said going in there he's suicide yeah it
seems like they got in there without it
being even remotely suicidal all of his
dudes are out front and this is a church
so it has other exits you I mean we know
so different you and I are not so
different cliche wait a minute my evil
boss's prayer is taking too long I'd
better go and circ myself into the plot
security fail you didn't even know about
the side entrance let alone have a guy
guarding it make it a couple of miles
out you're lucky your cars which are
souped up amazed at Ron's cannot
possibly outrun my guys cars which are
super duper souped-up amazed at Ron's
not fighting you know what are you
calling he should but somehow he'll not
have a proper escape plan boys that are
you gonna show up right after you say
this I'm sure how do the bad guys know
to show up to this random spot in the
middle of the Mexican desert
at best they got a message the boss was
kidnapped and the kidnappers were headed
out of town but all of them show up at
the same time and correctly guess which
spot outside of town to go to how was
their red station wagon in on this chase
this is a multi billion-dollar cartel
goddamn it all so how do these dumbass
cars catch up to the souped-up cute cars
the DOM and Brian drive how
your thoughts only one evil henchman is
smart enough to know this obvious rule
Tom head to the tunnel what's your
tunnel moment you just so happen to be
at the exact same stretch of US Mexican
border as earlier in the movie how
convenient
suddenly all the Mexicans miss my heart
after one time through these tunnels he
knows he can smash through the entrance
like this without killing himself for
all he knew that entrance was made of
steel but thankfully the correct answer
is paper mache Brian waits entirely too
long to do this Brian survives this um
awkwardness acknowledge the last time we
saw dawn his car got super banged up and
a bunch of cars were ripping into it and
causing various tunnel block issues now
the car looks essentially brand new and
is driving perfectly without any issue
thank God for film editing right that
makes people totally free it like that
no huge rocks are obviously falling in
front of dahm dahm caesar rocks and
raises you infinity and possible escape
instead of shooting Brian this moron
decides to monologue by kicking Brian
somehow grabs dude's leg to hold it in
place but also then isn't smashed by the
impact of Dom's car on this guy's body
I've listened to the testimony and taken
into special consideration agent
O'Conner's appeal of clemency on behalf
of mr. Toretto how does the judge
consider Brian's appeal since he's no
longer an agent and performed an illegal
operation in Mexico as a civilian what
was the point of that no longer on
active duty seen even prisoner transfer
buses drive on interstates with nobody
on them man at heists and prison breaks
with this easy everyone would do them
sorry disclaimer everyone who's dumb
enough to do the stunts from this movie
are already in the lobby talking about
how sick this movie is last time I saw
it was burger
you
jinkx is the driving cat cat who could
drive a car
only for moments and the moments go you
always say that the same thing every
time I'm through never again
too dangerous that's why I say I'm
always right - would you forget about it
in a day or two
yeah will days me forgetting or over
thank me remember it just begun sorry
how's the peeping tom they ran over here
they were followed the valise tracks
lead away from the battle into Fangorn
forest you know if I were driving this
long dangerous mission for Braga I'd
bring along some freaking snacks any
logical person would really which is why
none of these idiots did in the movie
you need variety too salty sweet salty
sweet what I'm saying really is that
these fast and furious guys could really
stand to benefit from signing up with
naturebox heck if you go to
naturebox.com/tyler Messines right now
courtesy of a special offer for our fans
you can get a free sampler box of their
most popular snacks wow that sounds like
this isn't some lame-o jelly of the
Month Club one-year membership from the
jelly of the Month Club
this is nature box hundreds of delicious
and healthy snacks delivered to your
door every month free to cancel anytime
but you won't want to because of the
deliciousness
like PB&J granola my absolute utmost
favorite thing to eat in the world
Yahweh so everybody let's all regards no
not that instead get thee to naturebox
calm and signup to get your free sampler
box today what you do after that is your
own business oh that's not right let's
go everyone all of you come on
no stragglers hey everybody if you have
an interest in a book about disabled
superhero kids I just happened to write
something like that and you can now
pre-order the eBook version the
audiobook is coming soon as well